it's gonna be annoying but i'm gonna be
like i have a dick
so
[Music]
i'm sam morrell i'm here to answer the
internet if you found a porn online of
your buddy and his girlfriend would you
watch it and would you say anything to
him here let's be real porn is they're
called a star for a reason you you make
that look good because of your ability
you watch just two people on camera
you're like this is just kind of two
people mushed together there's no
artistry so
i would not watch the completion but i
would watch it uh out of curiosity and
yeah i'd mention it would you rather
live your life as is or be a billionaire
but you have to blow a dude every day
well they say money can't buy happiness
and this is true right here i'm going to
go with life as is i don't want to wake
up every day and be like well i get to
go to a yacht but i got to do this one
thing right before what if nobody knew
that i would know yeah it's more about
you or is it more about the fact that
you're not it's assault you're being
sexually assaulted by your wealth what
if i get married to someone and then
she's like where have you been and i'm
just like i can't i don't wanna she's
like i feel like you're keeping
something i would she would find out and
it would it would it would the word
would get out at some point right but it
would be like you know do you like the
mansion honey do you like the yacht
we're gonna go on today then don't ask
away
i'm tony soprano but about yeah
i think i'm i think i'm gonna go with my
life as is and i and i blow who i choose
which is no one
if you had to win a game show to stay
alive which game show would you choose
the price is right it would be kind of
fun you know you stay alive but you also
win like a shitty washer and dryer it's
like a double it's a twofer you know if
you got ten thousand dollars a day for
every day you didn't masturbate how many
days could you last i didn't go like 30
days what no [ __ ] shot all right fine
two days
i'll go two days i feel like the sweet
spot like i would try to make it like
give me like 50k i'll have five days and
then i'll throw myself a party yes with
some high-end vaseline
it's 500 years from now and you're the
person in charge of naming this era what
would you call it i'd call it the like
ulta the ultra melting pot where
everyone not only we like diverse as
[ __ ]
but it's like it's weird how diverse we
are we call this the kill whitey era
if you're still like a purebred white
guy you're like look out we're in
trouble and i know i look pretty ethnic
but i'm like for that era i'm like as
white as it gets probably you know
would you rather have a dog die every
time you laugh we just killed one right
there
or have there be a genocide every time
you fall in love
i'm gonna go with the dead dog cause if
i could choose the dog it's maybe just
one of those ones from the pound that
gets euthanized you know
so you're like all right i mean that's
like it sucks but i'd rather have that
than like a
genocide is big i don't want to be
hitler just because i met some girl on
okcupid or something i'm in love right
now if it doesn't work out the jews have
to look out again sam make it work
please
there's a new guy coming to power who
looks pretty scary marry [ __ ] kill
italian food mexican food chinese food
you know what i'm gonna marry
mexican food because you can do a lot
with it i'm going to
[ __ ]
chinese food because it's like a good
one-night stand because you you stop and
you can keep going in like an hour you
know and italians are dead i'm sorry uh
not just the food the people i lose
christmas day without the chinese so
that's it's a no-brainer if you were gay
for a day who would you want to bang i
mean this is not something i put a lot
of thought into thankfully that'd be
weird if out of the gate i was like
clooney no question clooney brad pitt
maybe if you really put a thought into
it then
as a straight guy you'd be like it's a
little weird brad's a good answer
because he still looks good
and he's probably got some good stories
like if i were with a guy like the sex
isn't really appealing to me so if i'm
like if i'm gay for i mean i guess it
would be if i'm gay but the straight me
of thinking i want some good stories you
need someone who would treat i feel like
pitt would not treat you well no like he
would like i'd be like dude can we get
something to eat he's like we don't
really eat here i i work out and i do
like asha pops like [ __ ]
they said about leo uh the rumors that
he keeps his headphones in and you like
he only bends you over like you your
face away that's it really it's like i
don't even listen to you i don't talk to
you and you can't even look at me that's
like enough for me too these days we're
getting to a point where like he's not a
gentle lover is enough to be like he's
out i mean remember when dj khaled
almost got canceled he's like i don't i
don't do colonel lingas and everyone's
like you're disgusting
and it's like i mean just hands i mean
it's like i i do but like that's his
choice i guess right [ __ ] imagine i mean
some girl said she doesn't go down on
the guy she'd be celebrated as a hero
she'd be like you don't blow guys you're
you're incredible you're
this is a big boost for feminism you
gloria steinem would throw you a parade
if you could [ __ ] anyone you wanted but
they'd die immediately after who'd you
pick ann
coulter you want a [ __ ] call i don't
but it'd be funny if if i have to kill
someone i don't that's just the one that
popped in first i don't know if it's
right but that's all right
if you could put any franchise
restaurant in your house what would it
be
this is good what did the pressing pick
applebee's would be guys i got the hook
up here and they're like it's just
applebee's and you could've had anything
and you went you know it's not a
cheesecake factory's not a horrible pick
because they've got a huge menu i mean
chipotle would be nice if you had it all
hours because there's options that's
mexican food you do a burrito a bowl
some tacos a salad i guess cheesecake
factory just for the options if you
could only have four teeth in your
entire mouth where would they be i think
i'm going two here too here a little
symmetry
uh you know they're right in front it's
if you just have
them you can't chew
eat food
so that's like damn so i do it do i go
you have to just do two and two for like
food purposes my thing is two and two
you still don't look good
um so you're gonna like look like a
toothless freak anyway you might as well
be able to choose some food yeah you
will you're right
keep them back here and if women are
like you're toothless i'm like ah
check that out you rather have to heat
up all your food in 10 second increments
for the rest of your life or dive boner
first into a sidewalk one time i mean
how high up am i diving from just like
right from your feet right from the
ground
right onto it yeah i think i'm still
going i think i could break my dick that
way oh yeah oh yeah i'm going with it
i'm going with the that those 10 second
increments is going to be really
annoying for the rest of it it's going
to be annoying but i'm going to be like
i have a dick
so
i'm going to go with the with the food
one because i want to have a dick yeah i
think it's it's a weird one but i'm
going with the dick here
dude thank you man appreciate it
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon